um one whole area in your book that
there wasn't time for tonight but now
there is is what you draw from games in
the history of games and all of that in
this regard well I'm glad you asked
about that because you are a character
in that part of the book sure that
wasn't why you asked but so it's another
side of the history of computing that's
really interesting is how important in
addition to music how important games
are to the history of computing and one
of my favorite stories in the book
actually and I went back to the Computer
History Museum down in Menlo Park and
experienced this firsthand with my son
is the story of the game space war which
you play a role in and space for was
this getting really the first true kind
of thing that we would recognize as a
video game that was created in 1961 by a
bunch of we would call them now hackers
from MIT and they had this new
extraordinary computer that had a
monitor this was the big breakthrough
and so they were trying to figure they
can show graphics I was the PDP one and
they they were trying to figure what
we've got this monitor like what are we
gonna do with that and they were like
well what if we created a game a kind of
a space-themed game and so they created
this game which is really the antecedent
of asteroids if some of you remember
asteroids and this thing kind of takes
off and you could make the argument it's
one of the most important pieces of
software written in the 60s because it
kind of develops open-source style
through through the 60s and this code is
passed around and all these innovations
start happens one of the first examples
where you see an avatar representing
yourself on the screen that you can
control so it's the predecessor in a way
of a kind of a mouse icon and so on or a
pointer there's also one of the early
pushers of time-sharing because they
were trying to make these big basically
mainframe and then so-called many
computers act like a personal computer
and people would add all these features
to it like one guy created this program
called expensive planetarium which
recreated the night sky accurately it's
one of the first times in a kind of
non-military application you had actual
realistic renderings of reality on a
computer screen again for no purpose
what they've actually added nothing to
the game whatsoever it was just stars
kind of in the background and what it
then eventually it it kind of you know
it's one of the first in a sense of
open-source software projects as well so
all these ideas that become crucial to
computing develop out of it but then one
of the things that happens is this kid
Stewart Brand goes and organizes the
space for Olympics at Stanford and
writes about it for Rolling Stone and
through watching these people with this
you know rapturous relationship to this
game on the screen he begins to think
you know compute as these rights
computers are coming to the people and
then the next line of that article is
that's the best news since psychedelics
because it was 1972 whatever so here you
have this game and yet it ended up
playing a really kind of defining role
in in the history of computers in that
period